well he was a man who had it all blessed
with a brilliant brain he was a king
scholar Eaton got a double first at
Cambridge he was a Kennedy scholar at
Harvard and then he added a PhD to his
name his first taste of the Limelight
light was way back in 1995 when he was a
member of the team that won the BBC quiz
show University challenge after a stint
in the city he landed one of the safest
seats in the country becoming a
conservative MP in 2010 he then worked
his way up to the second most powerful
political position in the country as
Britain's first black Chancellor
quasi-quarting is one of those annoying
people that are good at almost
everything except perhaps looking after
our cash because within 38 days of his
appointment to the treasury it was all
over his first budget had blown up and
his close friends and political Ally Liz
truss had thrown him to the wolves in a
vain attempt to save her own skin and
the ultimate humiliation he actually
learned he was about to be fired when he
read it on Twitter well reeling from one
of the most shocking political betrayals
in modern history and amid accusations
he'd crashed the economy quasi quite
understandably went to ground now he's
finally ready to talk live about how his
career went up in smoke along with his
vision for the UK economy
well the former Chancellor
quasi-quarting joins us now hello thanks
for being with us you blew that pretty
badly didn't you quasi well it was a
turbulent time I mean we can laugh about
it but we were trying to do a serious
thing we try to reduce uh the tax uh
burden on this country and uh we were
caught in a in a real Firestorm and I
think
um it's a shame what happened uh I do
regret some of the things that we did in
terms of the speed but I think the
general direction in terms of lowering
taxes right well look before we get on
to all that I I want to just step back a
minute I mean this is your first uh live
interview since you left office you're
kind of off the leash aren't you I mean
previously you've always had to watch
what you say because you were in cabinet
for a very long time for quite a long
time I mean I was and there was a
minister or PPS of the chancellor which
is you know very uh it's taken a junior
Adventure but you're kind of on them but
you still have to watch what yeah you're
part of what they call the paper so I
hope you're not going to hold back um
well I'm going to speak uh as as freely
as I can but but what I would say is
that I was in those jobs as a PPS
whatever for about seven years yes
um and now this is the first time really
since 2015 I think probably 2014 that
I've had a live interview as as a
backbencher well look um before we move
on to All Things economic which I Know
Rich is absolutely itching to get into
let's talk for a minute about now
Nicholas sturgeon you know this is the
big story of the world absolutely
um what do you make of her sudden
resignation I think it's been
fascinating uh I mean I just found out
about it uh again on Twitter
um and it was very sudden I mean she
said oh she'd been thinking about it a
lot but really the straw that broke the
camel's back as you'll remember was the
I think he was called Adam Graham when
he was a man and then he had surgery and
and was called either Bryson and this
man had been convicted of rape twice and
then was put into a woman's uh prison
which defines all common sense and I
think Nicola trying to to say that this
was the right thing to do and she got
herself into lots of knots was really
the straw to break the camel's back her
her ratings are plunged and essentially
her woke agenda ended up blowing up in
her face
I mean she got herself into a hell of a
model as you say
um I don't know whether you remember
clip of her getting into a real twist
over the definition of a woman and you
know whether a trans woman is a woman
what is a woman as far as you're
concerned well a woman is somebody like
my mother who gave who gives birth or
can has a capacity to give birth to
children
the question that she got into a pickle
over is are trans women women well that
was that was a great I mean I don't
think biologically they are I think you
can call them what you will but
biologically they're clearly not yeah
she's really how so many senior
politicians are getting in such a pickle
I mean it's it's pretty obvious it's
pretty basic stuff isn't it it is but I
think the work agenda has just taken
over and finicky I mean she's a very
able politician I mean to her credit
she's lasted eight years which is a lot
longer than certainly I was Chancellor
but but but but actually she got herself
into a terrible pickle on uh these quite
basic issues and I think the work agenda
essentially just just I mean but the
truth is and you talk about the worker
gender as if it exists sort of has a
life of its own but the truth is that
the work agenda is pretty Rife
throughout all our institutions now I
mean take the NHS for example
um do you think your own party may
possibly have been a bit too timid on on
these issues no I think if you speak to
people like uh Kenny badnock or Michael
Gove uh they've been pretty clear about
about you know fundamentals on this and
I think it's very easy for people
politicians to get completely muddled
and defy common sense and I think if you
speak to people like Kenny bird knock
others in the conservative party there
is very much a common sense approach to
a lot of these questions okay
um just let's move on because there's
been a recently some pretty awful
apparently racially aggravated attacks
including one um I believe alleged in
your own constituency
um that's obviously going to fuel claims
that Britain is a racist Society what's
your take on so my view broadly is that
Britain I mean you look at any country
in the world Britain is a pretty
tolerant place I mean you look at you
know the fact the prime minister is from
an ethnic background I was in cabinets
with lots of colleagues who are from
ethnic backgrounds that's that's a huge
deal that doesn't mean that there is no
racism in Britain I mean that's do you
feel that you've ever in your whole life
have you ever encountered I can tell you
growing up in the 80s in London was was
much more racially aggravated much there
was much more tension than there is
today I mean you regularly get abuse on
the tube right frequently
um there was open uh hostility to ethnic
minorities in a way that you don't see
very much today now I'm not saying it's
a perfect world that we live in in terms
of racial Harmony there are still
outstanding issues but I think Britain
has come a very long way uh in the 40
years that I've I can remember I mean in
The Firestorm after your um resignation
or firing however we're going to call it
um you know all sorts of stuff was being
held at you yeah was there any racially
motivated I didn't really
um get involved in that I mean I'm not a
Twitter Warrior I deliberately avoid
getting down those uh rabbit holes
because you can get into all sorts of
fights you know some of my colleagues
are tweeting all the time yeah and
they're in these kind of crazy battles
so I avoided that
um and I wasn't really plugged into a
lot of that critics did you go into
hiding somewhat no well when you're
getting doorsteps yeah as I was Yeah by
media I I just um fled
um
but I I because I knew what would happen
I knew that they would and every day
there were people but after about four
or five days the story moved on so when
I came back I came back to my house
there was nobody there it was about six
days later the truth was though Liz
truss made a catastrophic mistake firing
you I mean you were in it together and
you had to survive it together yeah and
I think I think we've got a clip here of
her trying to sort of defend that
decision yeah let's let's just look at
that
see you know I'm
I can't I can't say it was anything but
extremely difficult but
he was in Washington at the time at the
um IMF meeting
and you know I was getting some very
serious warnings from senior officials
that the you know there could be a
potential Market meltdown
the following week
if I didn't take action and
I needed to do as much as I could
to indicate that things were different
how do you how do I get that but thanks
for watching that I mean I was looking
at your expression
um you looked pretty pissed off I have
to well look you know the fact was she
had a very successful leadership
Campaign which was all about not putting
up tax and I was very clear and I said
it repeatedly that we were going to be
joined at the hip and that was what I
was there to do and so I was in
Washington as you as as she mentioned
and I was summoned back I should have
stayed an extra day but my thinking was
well this is just gonna add you know
create more drama should you have gone
at all because actually so it was wrong
there was they were sort of there was
there was conspiratorial activity going
on behind you back but it was one of
those things if I hadn't gone it would
have been a massive deal
it was six of one half a dozen of the
other you were damned if you did you
were damned if you didn't if I hadn't
gone it would have been the first time
since God knows when that a British
Chancellor hadn't gone to the annual
meeting yeah in the IMF and that would
have been the story so she so so that
that you know it was it was a difficult
call she said she had no option I'm
quoting here she had no option but to
sack you do you agree well of course I I
don't agree I mean I I think we could
have
um we should have actually worked
together but you know I'm not you should
have toughed it out do you think well I
mean tough it out I think I think the
one thing that I would say is that in
any political it's a general point in
any difficulty in any um you know a
strong stressful uh situation where
people are buffeting you know lots of
people buffing around the one thing you
have to do is you know you've got to I
think people have a very calm approach
but leadership that was what that was
what I wanted to do
um and I thought summoning me back a day
before the everyone could see it I mean
it was my plane was being tracked
you know by thousands of people
um and and it just Shone a huge light on
the fact that there was this turmoil but
you know these are finally judged
finally balanced questions and the Prime
Minister you know was was was advised
she took a difficult decision she said
it to me it was a difficult decision but
at that point when I was sacked I knew
that there wouldn't be much longer of a
Premiership and actually I think I was
it was reported uh she panicked well
look I mean I don't want to be funny
would that be fair but I I mean if the
if the if the argument was I'm gonna
sack my Chancellor so that I can prolong
my political life I don't think six days
uh it was a sign of massive success in
that do you feel let down by your
officials uh possibly by the sacking of
Tom scholar and indeed let down by the
bank of England if they'd acted
differently on that Monday morning if
they'd started buying some bombs things
could have been very very difficult well
they've been committed to that I think
the whole um I think Tom skull I've said
I said it publicly at the time it's been
forgotten was an excellent civil servant
but he'd been there 30 years but you
fired it and yeah you know but he wasn't
he got a Knighthood it was the The Press
said oh this is a total
um you know it shows that they got it
wrong but he'd had 30 years
um and we felt that it was time for him
what about the bank of England
I think the governor of the bank had got
on quite well uh with him in the short
time I was uh working with him people
had said that um they had you know
interest rates hadn't gone up uh quickly
enough there was there was a lot of
chatter around that but I had a good
working relationship with the governor
well what was quite extraordinary is
that having sacked you uh Liz truss then
chose Jeremy Hunt as your replacement
now she's not close to Jeremy Hunt so
where did that idea come from well I I
don't know you'd have to ask the Prime
Minister but I think it was it's quite
odd that in her essay she's been talking
about the uh you know the fact that the
treasury did this and did that but she
appointed Jeremy hunts I mean that was
do you think someone told do you think
someone else I don't think so I think
she she had it why did she do it then um
because she wanted to stabilize the
markets I think they had uh I think
Jeremy did a good job in that and it's
very much now you know let's try and
stabilize things and not and not uh get
too excitable don't try and agitate how
would you characterize Hunt's ideology I
think I think it's a very Orthodox
um treasury I
it's all about being boring or being
exciting it's about an approach to
economic management yeah and I think
what he's doing is is trying to
stabilize the market that's what he's
been brought in to do by Liz truss
absolutely contacted him it wasn't Rishi
the budget's looming now um fortunately
for you you're not in charge
um but clearly something has to be done
about the tax burden doesn't it it's way
too high well look I mean that was the
whole premise of the leadership contest
that we had in the summer which Liz won
but of course you know what happened in
in October or September happened and now
we've got a new prime minister and a new
Chancellor and their job and I think
they're doing a good job at it actually
is to try and stabilize uh the markets
which they have done I think that's been
successful and they've always said that
they want to reduce taxes when it's
appropriate to do so yeah the question
is when when is that well the reality is
we've got companies like AstraZeneca
Britain's biggest publicly listed
company announcing this week that
they're setting up a new base in Dublin
um you know citing tax Reasons by the
way because corporation tax is so much
lower there how do you see the
implications of that look so I think
that we had uh will there be more that
do that I don't know I don't know I mean
I think I mean I've always been very
clear about the fact that I don't think
High tax you get to Prosperity by um
high taxes I don't think that's the
route to do it is the risks that a
growing number of wealth creators are
just going to leave there's always a
risk when you put taxes up there's
always a risk for people who generate
wealth
um decide to do up sticks and go
somewhere else and that's what Pascal
sorio the head of AstraZeneca who I know
um and I used to speak to when I was a
business secretary
um he made that he made that very clear
in his statement and how do you feel
about that I think it's regrettable I
think they're a great company and I hope
they would come back and maybe
reconsider their decision
and for three years you were first a
minister of State in the Department of
Business and then you became Secretary
of State and as a Secretary of State for
business in a brexit government I mean
the whole thing was take control of our
money our laws and our borders yeah you
had a great opportunity to start to cut
back on the mountain of Daft
bureaucratic EU laws and you did nothing
about no we didn't we started on that I
mean though Jacob was brought in Jacob
Reese Moore was brought in as a minister
in the cabinet office we looked at
regulation we've got a bill that's
coming through which is going to get rid
of a lot of the the EU regulations but
in reality come on you know that Bill's
not going to go through no I think it
has a chance I don't know let's talk
about declaring a pre-judge I never
pre-judge legislation but that's clearly
the statement of the intent of the
government but there's yes but the
establishment is trying to delay it now
by three or four years to 2026. you know
we left in nine at the end of 19 in the
end of the transition period was the end
of 20 that's right we brexiteers we said
to the country we deregulate we'd go for
growth we'd cut taxes with controller
borders yeah you had a major opportunity
to cut the regulation and you really had
to start we did start I mean the thing I
would say about the whole EU debate a
bit of perspective we were in this thing
we're in the EU for nearly 50 years
certainly before I was born okay and I
think that a lot of it won't take 50
years to get the benefits it shouldn't
do but having been this we're having
pressure now having been in it for 50
years I think it was a lot to expect
that immediately we left suddenly
everything would be uh hunky-dory that
wasn't realistic and the other thing
that people have forgotten about and you
you mentioned my whatever departments I
was in I was also in the brexit
department
for about nine months so even more you
didn't take advantage yeah but at that
time Richard you'll remember in 2017 we
didn't have a majority I mean it was a
completely confused situation in terms
of where the department I I accepted in
2017. so between 2017 and 90. so for
three years essentially but between we
were in gridlock and then Boris actually
managed to to liberate the uh the grid a
lot then kovid came three months later
but but you weren't involved with covert
you should have been preparing all of
this stuff to just slash and burn these
dark regulations and you didn't we had a
legislation we had we had we have
legislation in place I worked on that
Jacob has worked on that and it's going
through the house of the parliament well
rather than raking over what's now
ancient history what about where we are
now do you think I mean we've got Jeremy
Hahn in the in number 11
um he was a remainer and Rishi sunak was
a brexitude I don't know whether he's a
convincing one uh you've heard about the
ditchley park Gathering I mean I've been
to those Gatherings you sadly weren't
invited funnily enough
um I mean do you is there a danger that
there is a move to slide us back into
the I think there is a risk of that
absolutely I think that but I mean you
heard I think Michael Hazeltine say this
earlier um on your show he just says
well oh the brick steers have messed it
up then let's go back into the EU and of
course they're not stupid they're not
going to say oh let's rejoin the EU but
they'll Dress It Up in some form of of
Words which essentially means that we'll
be in the US of your own on worst terms
I don't know I think the party is
committed I know the Prime Minister
Rishi is committed what about Jeremy
delivering a brexit well the Prime
Minister I mean he's running the
government so he's the one it's one
thing having left yeah but you've got to
take advantage of the opportunities and
two years later after the end of the
transition period yeah you've got
nothing as a government as a
conservative party to chauffeur I think
we've got quite a lot to show for
elections but if you look if you look at
the the big debate in the you'll
remember this because we were on the
same side was the amount we were putting
into the EU okay that was 10 billion in
the old budget uh framework it was 10
billion a year it would have been more
in the 20 in the new budget framework
that's so if you think that's nearly six
years of where we would be paying 10
so on borders at least we've got an
immigration policy
doesn't count for anything no one cares
about a policy quasi we want to control
our board no policy does matter because
um what was happening before is we were
having 150 000 people coming into the
country that we had no control over
whatsoever have you got any control over
the migrant boots I think we are trying
to get uh more of a grip on that but we
have a little grip on it at the moment
but in terms of immigration Isabel we
have a lot more say we've got a lot more
uh control of what our policies
the current Home Secretary admitted that
you had lost control of the borders
she's she's she admitted that to I
believe a select committee I didn't see
last year to June 2022 and the year was
the highest ever uh lawful immigration
so essentially you've sold to the nation
as a government you've sold a pup you
said brexit was all about controlling
our borders and we've got record levels
of lawful immigration and we've got
record levels of unlawful so brexit as I
remember was not about banning it all
immigration
record levels no but you know for the
and I'm someone who I think we should be
able to attract the best absolutely
agree into the country I don't see any
problem with that and in many instances
people still want to come here which is
a good thing is that talent coming over
on boots no I mean they've got to do it
legally okay it's got to be legal it
can't be trafficking it can't be because
I feel any of that kind of Defending
Your government's record and remember
you are a backbencher now so you can you
can speak freely I I am but I'm also a
team player I mean I find it very
frustrating how do you honestly feel
about the never-ending numbers coming
over illegally on boats really
frustrating it's extremely frustrating
and also well I'm not a bad
I'm focused I'm trying to come up with
Solutions and the other thing that I
would stress is that you know there are
too many people who you know having been
ministers go on the back benches and
then just freely slag off the government
and don't give the measure of support
when they were ministers they expected
backbenders to support them so they
should be supporting us backbenchers for
government talking of support obviously
one of the things that you're involved
was was the price of energy the cost of
energy which was going through the roof
yeah and essentially the cost of energy
is it's the other side of the net zero
coin yeah that is the reality and we've
now got a situation where the
government's subsidizing People's Energy
bills and we've got businesses we talked
touched on AstraZeneca the other massive
problem for businesses is the cost of
energy yeah the car industry is
collapsing Ford just yesterday announced
1300 layoffs as they move towards
electrification yeah there are three
thousand across Europe
jlr are moving production overseas
mainly because of the cost of energy and
to do with Net Zero the steel industry
is begging for 100 hundreds of millions
of handouts because of the cost of
energy because of Net Zero many other
firms particularly Hospitality pubs
restaurants their energy bills are going
through the roof they're shutting when
they get off their existing tariffs this
is all because of Net Zero it's all
because of Net Zero
it's not all about the cost of energy
right is directly linked to the move
towards Renewables we're subsidizing 11
billion to Offshore offshore wind farms
there's a lot of five billion of
balancing costs that people have to pay
for and the truth is net zero is making
us poorer it's making us colder
and you're responsible no look I totally
disagree with you the idea that Nets it
just burning more coal and and burning
fossil fuels is that is the future I
think is wrong it's false if you look at
the costs of energy what was driving it
at the in the winter of 2021 was the
fact that China essentially came out of
covered restrictions and there was huge
demand coming out of China for gas and
that pushed the price up and the second
double whammy we had was of course
Putin's Invasion we had something to do
sitting on nothing he's worth of our own
energy treasure though look it's not
just fracking we've got we've got
onshore gas we've got onshore
we've got all these things we're not
we're not exploiting did you see the
profits of centrica today yes that's a
lot of that's from from British
but that's what that's what they do but
the reality is we've we've got all this
Shale gas yeah you know you and Liz
briefly uh wanted to sort of I was never
a big fracker because I realized but but
there was a big political problem you
say that the cost of energy is nothing
you can do about it in America the cost
of their energy their gas is a quarter
of ours why because they're fracking
because they're using their own domestic
energy they'll give you a self-reliant
on it and and you as a government to
bottled it so look in Wyoming there are
two people per square kilometer okay in
Lancashire where there was uh some
preliminary fracking uh undertaken it's
about 450 people okay so your ability to
get through any political pressures by
Frankie in Wyoming is far greater than
is the case in England so final question
final question is there a risk The Net
Zero agenda has gone too far I think the
Net Zero agenda is absolutely the right
agenda
do you really I think it's yeah
absolutely you are destroying this
nurture his economy you are making
people the idea that you can burn coal
like we did in the 50s forever and ever
thank you so much completely absurd
thank you so much for joining us it's
gone way too quick we have to have you
back on again